Paris the so-called city of love people
travel from all over the world to
celebrate their emotions but since I've
been here I've been wondering about
Frances feelings for its football team
an hour's drive out of Paris I hope to
find some answers at the home of French
football normally the team is closed off
but today is special today fans are here
to watch their country's footballers in
action how important is it for you to be
here today so close to the team it's
real important there because we get to
the please and give them the just trains
to wheel Antoine Griezmann adds to the
love all around the training pitch as
does Paul Pogba ten minutes after time
with the fans training begins France are
keen not to slip up against Iceland team
that has won the hearts of many watching
on I can't help but wonder why this
country's capital hasn't fallen in love
with this team when I speak to local
journalists it sounds like Paris is
spoiled for choice and that when it
comes to football the capital is playing
hard to get and this is great defense
and special and this is very special
thing in Paris that's why is not the
good news for friends to play at the
stat de France because it's call it
still nearly lasted 15 minutes for
example the public will put a lot of
pressure on the team and when you ask
the player they all said the same thing
we don't really like to play at least at
the constant gift-giving is part of any
healthy relationship and the French
players make sure to do their bit at the
end of the training session
as far as I can see it seems to be
working what was that like watching the
players why was it was great
whether very very cool to see them yes
it's our time it's our time and hi oppa
we are going to win Paris is no
Marseille but slowly it's catching on
and the hope now is the Paris find space
in its heart to cheer on the French team